es otra desgracia en plena guerra este
miércoles un helicóptero se estrelló
cerca de una guardería mientras
sobrevolaba en las afueras de kiev entre
las víctimas mortales el ministro de
interior de Ucrania y varios menores de
edad que se encontraban en el jardín
oímos gritos había niños corriendo y
empezamos a ayudar pasaban niños por
encima de la valla y conseguimos agarrar
a tres un niño y dos niñas
oímos una explosión salimos corriendo mi
hija corrió a buscar a mi nieta que va a
la guardería nos la llevamos Todo estaba
Ardiendo ahí los autos cerca del
edificio estaban Ardiendo al
precipitarse el helicóptero un superpuma
francés provocó un fuerte incendio que
redujo gran parte del edificio a cenizas
entre los nueve pasajeros fallecidos se
encontraban el secretario de estado y
viceministro de interior junto al
titular de la cartera Dennis monastir
nombrado por el presidente zelenski en
era un chico joven muy patriótico que
hizo muchas cosas por Ucrania y por la
reforma de la policía en el país
por el momento se desconocen las causas
del suceso que apunta a ser un accidente
sin embargo las autoridades ucranianas
han anunciado una investigación al
respecto
desgraciadamente es solo otro día
horrible para Ucrania desde fuera puede
parecer que ya estamos acostumbrados a
estas cosas pero desgraciadamente no lo
estamos
el helicóptero se dirigía a nipro uno de
los puntos calientes de la guerra donde
hace cuatro días un ataque ruso se saldó
con la vida de 44 personas